guys denial eSports is a name that comes
with a lot of baggage over the years
they've been mired in reports of late
payments non-existent payments failure
to pay salary and prize money and now
they're back in the news for all the
wrong reasons so a lot of you guys
probably heard of denial eSports before
they've been in and out of eSports for
years they fielded rosters and
everything from overwatch to h1z1 csgo
they've had fighting game players names
like X Q CT foo and clay ster have been
a part of this Oregon various times but
I'm willing to bet that's probably not
the reason you know denial if you've
been in eSports for a long time you
might be familiar with their sordid
history of alleged failed payments but
even if you haven't you probably heard
about this latest issue this time around
repayments to former Cod and Gears of
War players now we're going to go over
everything that happened in the last few
weeks but first to understand denials
present and future we have to understand
their past to understand why these
recent allegations and issues are so
troubling and so egregious here is what
I hope will be a pretty quick timeline
of the shitshow of events that led to
this week's news let's start all the way
back in September of 2015 when denial
allegedly owed their former halo squad
$3,000 shortly after that their CEO at
the time Robby ring nald up put out a
pretty strange twit longer that
ostensibly was unrelated to the halo
team but said things like don't pay your
players if they're not quote promoting
the brands that make the orgs tick end
quote
flash-forward to January of 2017 melee
player duck allegedly left the org
because of lack of payment according to
an ESPN report now after that report
came out the payments suddenly went
through and everything was good with
them throughout that same year 2017
denial
apparently owed their csgo team between
40,000 and 60,000 dollars according to a
slingshot report the CS team were
allegedly in such a tight spot that they
had to borrow money from friends and
family just to keep the lights on at the
team house also in the first half of
that same year 2017 denials
rocket League team and fighting game
player Krista Tyrion received multiple
late payments for their services again
according to slingshot throughout this
whole period denial apparently failed to
pay many staff members as well with
their CEO Ronaldo
making vague excuses and alluding to big
changes that were coming on the horizon
he also offered some former employees
equity in the company in lieu of actual
pay on 2 September of 2017 when
pineapples who was then an h1z1 player
for denial and his now streamer signed
echovox by the way releases a twit
longer saying that he and the rest of
the denial h1z1 team were leaving that
org for allegedly being owed twenty-two
thousand dollars in prize money that was
never paid out to them this by the way
it was a team that included a little
gamer you may have heard of named T foo
CEO Robbie Ronaldo chalked the whole
thing up to an unfortunate banking error
like he was playing [ __ ] Monopoly hey
after this multiple staff members began
to leave the org themselves this is
truly the beginning of the end for what
we knew as denial eSports and sometime
in 2018 he word quietly shuddered and
shut down and Ronaldo disappeared from
the scene in September of 2018 two law
firms Morrison Lee and ESG released
joint statement saying that denial CEO
Robbie Ronaldo owes the csgo team salary
housing expenses and tournament entry
fees totaling around $35,000 they say
players from quote virtually all of the
other teams under denial at the time
were in similar situations they go so
far as to specifically call out Ronaldo
saying there's no place in eSports for
people like him and he should never work
in eSports again and thus ends the
unfortunate story of the first era of
denial now just a few short months later
in December of 2018 denial is back baby
a gentleman by the name of Zack Smith
who comes from a place called money
matches which is a data analytics and
mock gambling site buys denial and he
does a pretty incredible thing right
from the get-go he pledges to take on
all of the expenses all of the debt all
of the
alleged owed prize money and salaries
from the old denial can repay everyone
who is wronged or claimed they were
wronged and make it alright well what
it's the right thing to do
diets you know the players got [ __ ]
the you know people got burned and there
was a big hole left in the industry with
denial even now why would he do this
obviously it's not out of the goodness
of his own heart well he said in one
interview that simply the cost to debt
ratio made sense to him and that
acquiring a known brand with already
existing cash a in eSports was worth the
cost of repaying everyone and in the
short term it was positive news Zack
Smith was releasing statements about how
denial was gonna make these goodwill
payments and set a new standard in
eSports he was gonna make everything
right and start from a clean slate
remember that as we proceed through this
next section and even though he does as
previously stated admit that teams got
[ __ ] under the old denial he also
seems to think that Robbie Ronaldo is
not such a bad guy saying quote he's not
a bad person
he just did a wrong thing end quote
friggin Alda for his part and this will
be the last we hear of him for a while
released a tweet in January of this year
admitting he made mistakes and saying he
mismanaged the brand but he says that
the new CEO and co-owner Zack Smith has
righted all his wrongs or will write all
his wrongs January 27 2009 teen xqc
comes right out of the gate on stream i
saw tweets saying then i'll played all
their old players as edited that is
scanned right we paid all their players
guys they chained it all the players I
did not get an email and you get at the
end and you get a message and you get
nothing from them not a single thing it
and later on I said no teammates nobody
or anything except one person
they said they offered $200 out of the
2.8 or 2.4 thousand of the dist all
right and then they say oh we made all
the players whole know not only did you
not do it you're gonna empower should we
do it and on top that I can't I can't I
can't
yeah I'm done shortly after that Zack
Smith who you'll remember is now the new
face of denial he's the co-owner
responded telling eSports betting a new
site unicorn that they tried to get in
contact with xqc
after his dream in order to read
pay him and his teammates but xqc did
not respond and couldn't be reached
January 28 2019 two big signings are
announced
number one denial signs the players from
a cod team called overtime who qualified
for the call of duty world league they
also sign a csgo squad which was
formerly bravado gaming April 19th 2019
denial drops most of that overtime call
a duty roster and signs the core players
from Red Reserve May 13 2009 teen one of
denials now former Cod players one of
the guys from the overtime roster by the
name of NAT che releases a statement
alleging he and his teammates are owed
unpaid salary bonus money and travel
expenses all from there few months on
denial he says they agreed on five
thousand dollars a month in salary which
was apparently delayed when they arrived
in Columbus Ohio to compete for their
world league matches then comes more
trouble at a boot camp in Las Vegas
where NAT che alleges he had to pay for
players rooms himself for several nights
and that the org only paid for one night
of hotel rooms for the team now
zachsmith
responded to this on the denial side and
refuted some of the claims saying that
NAT che and his team signed agreements
understanding that any salary payment
was dependent on obtaining a p1 a work
visa in the u.s. NAT che and his
teammates are French nationals a p1 a
visa is basically for international
athletes to travel to the US and do
competitions there and be compensated
for them Matt Shay for his part denies
this was ever made clear to him and his
teammates and he says he never agreed to
those terms
a few days after NAT che made these
original allegations over time the or
denial bought their cod team off of and
their corresponding world league spot
from claimed earlier this month that
denial has owed them quote tens of
thousands of euros from that transaction
and that the alleged failure of denial
to pay them those tens of thousands of
euros has meant that over time has been
completely inactive since they sold
their roster and their world league spot
that same day Zack Smith the co-owner
stepped down from day-to-day operations
at denial refuting some but not all of
matches claimed while not commenting on
the over
allegations and continuing to reaffirm
that this new look denial is trying to
do the right thing and set a new
standard in eSports one day later May 16
2009 teen dot a Sports reported that
according to their own sources denial
owed a total of more than 110,000
dollars to their former players and to
overtime allegedly according to their
sources it went like this
the players and the org signed letters
of intent that said that the players
would be entitled to salary Zach Smith
then allegedly presented them with
contracts that did not include salary at
all according to at least one dot
eSports source the team or members of
the team may have even been coerced into
signing this with denial allegedly
telling them they had to sign it or they
just wouldn't get to play in a Twitter
statement Smith said that denial had set
up an escrow account to pay quote the
player which were guessing is nat che
and his quote alleged own salaries
escrow of course just meaning an account
that is administered by a third party
now if you thought we were done
we're not May 28th 2009 teen was Tuesday
a former denial Cod player by the name
of profit now he was one of the old
denial players not one from the overtime
roster said that the goodwill payments
made to him by Zach Smith were being
rescinded he posted a screenshot showing
that the February payment had apparently
been disputed by Smith several other X
denial players specifically Gears of War
guys had similar things happen now right
after that Smith came out and said that
these payments which were made earlier
in the year were flagged by his credit
card company and that's why the payments
were being disputed because they were
viewed as suspicious by his credit card
company he said he has since fixed the
situation with this credit card company
and provided Dex ear toe with
screenshots to prove it and that ladies
and gentlemen at least to this point is
the sordid saga of the denial eSports
controversy what's crazy to me about
this whole situation is that this new
look denial under completely new
management not involving that Ringold a
guy at all is acting exactly like the
old denial there's a couple common
threads that bind the old denial to the
new denial one is obviously all these
allegations
of failure to pay their players or late
payments another one is often having
these unfortunate bank or credit card
incidents come up in the way of payments
and another one is that when a player or
a team goes public or threatens to go
public their situation improves
dramatically very quickly now if we were
to do a where are they now on rigged
Alda well after leaving denial he
co-founded a company that made craft
beer biscuits for dogs as of right now
denials apparent failure to compensate
over time for their world league spot
and their former Cod roster is ongoing
this simply can't continue the new
denial can't keep acting like the old
denial and some would say maybe it's
already too late for redemption
obviously I don't work for denial I'm
not signed to denial and I've never had
any personal or business dealings with
denial so I'm just gonna leave you with
these words from csgo superstar ilish
that were tweeted earlier this week
quote any csgo players do yourself a
favor and never talk to denial eSports
save yourself some trouble and don't
deal with orgs that have been infamously
Shady
slash scummy for their entire existence
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
bring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]